alright let me start with you and Rodney
said last night the Texan should sign
colin kaepernick some of the things that
you said sign colin kaepernick you don't
have a have good quarterback play when
you have a mobile quarterback your
offense looks different there is a
mobile quarterback out there go get him
and colin kaepernick all right i think
it's crazy to bring in Colin Kaepernick
now because I don't think he's ready to
play football if Garoppolo wasn't ready
to play for the Niners and he's been
playing Colin Kaepernick can't play
right now he won't help them this week
if they sign him but he could help him
down the road we thought deshaun Watson
wasn't ready to play we got that well we
knew we knew he was we kept saying how
is Tom savage beating out deshaun Watson
but he was ready to play football
Kaepernick is not ready to play in an
NFL game anytime soon the concern I have
is if he does come back he's not ready
to play doesn't play well then people
are gonna say why the big deal about
Colin Kaepernick so if he does come back
and he gets a chance to play I hope they
give him ample time to get ready they
don't need that but don't don't just
look at it for these four weeks either
deshaun Watson is your future this is
what your offense is going to look like
to have somebody who can do some of the
same things down the road next year if
this happens you're in better shape so
I'm just saying what they're doing that
we all heard this while Colin Kaepernick
can only play in certain type of attacks
they have that type of attack now that's
what they do it makes sense to me yeah I
also look at at Houston and that
ownership if they would welcome in Colin
Kaepernick as well and Plus you know the
president is going to go after any owner
team who signs Colin Kaepernick you know
you're getting that so you you have to
be ready for quite a few things is
Kaepernick good enough for all of this
is really the king that that's the
question you have to ask I happen to
think he would help them and I think
he'd help him in the long run and that's
what I would look at if I was coaching
I'd say can this guy help my team in the
long run we talked about Tampa you know
how I feel about Tampa that it their
success hinges on the maturity of Jameis
Winston
I really believe that because I do think
they can get it right in other facets
here
why does Jameis Winston take two steps
forward and two steps back Tony he's a
young man and he's got to grow through
that I'm worried about that off the
field I was always worried about that
he's done well that win in Tampa has not
had any issues off the field in the
community taking care of the football
that's your number one job he hasn't
done a great job of that he's still
plays like he's got to make every play
and every throw and win the games
himself he's got to learn that situation
like yesterday can't happen if you're
the leader how do you not throw out my
Kevin [ __ ] like what I know you can't
review that but if you're an official
the officials are very hesitant to throw
people out of games you just see it over
and over and over again you know we saw
AJ green and Ramsay get tossed but
that's right in front of an official it
was almost involved in the scrum I don't
know how you know Mike Evans comes from
50 yards away and clips the guy from
behind I'm not sure how he's not thrown
out either that that's one that you just
shake your head that you don't know okay
how would you feel as the coach if your
dirt cutter that Mike Evans is sticking
up for your quarterback not knowing
exactly what happened and that Winston
instigated you're fine with that
that part of it you got to stick up for
your teammates especially your
quarterback Mike Evans is running a
route he doesn't see what happens and
all of a sudden his quarterback is
getting pushed on the sidelines so that
immediate response you're okay with that
but you're talking to the whole team we
cannot lose our composure like this we
have to be more professional we've got
to win games and not blow them and not
give ourselves this just I did it we're
out of control and so I think you talked
to the whole team and say you know what
we've got to play better we've got to be
better
Denver gives up 51 and the Giants give
up 51 Denver is more surprising to give
up 51 even though it's to an eagle good
Eagles team the Giants gave up 51 at
home to the RAM I'm gonna offer by you
just did not expect that
I thought this was going to be kind of
the Last Stand we're gonna come back
we're gonna play well started with the
suspension of Jenkins then you see block
punts and just not no hustle on the
defense it was very very surprising to
me I did not expect to see that from the
time but when do you know your team has
given up you kind of see a pattern of it
and it was it was ugly yesterday I don't
know that those guys have given up but
they didn't want to check some guys
didn't want to tackle and see the
problem Rodney Harrison said and you
remember it at the beginning the year
this defense can be great this can be
better than the Superbowl defense they
can carry them and that's what you're
expecting so when you see that and when
you see guys run through the team on
third and 37 when you see just gigantic
holes and nobody hustling and long
passes this is supposed to be the
strength of our team what happened and I
can't explain it
the Rams blueprint great defense you
finally get it
a head coach who understands offense and
quarterbacks which is something Jeff
Fischer did not but is it that something
that simple I know you shored up the
offensive line but why is it clicked for
the Rams this year so quickly it really
has good quarterback play this front
seven has been dominant for a couple
they've had team speed they've given
Seattle problems four years with their
defensive line they've got speed in the
secondary Todd Gurley is a very very
good back they've got some receivers who
can make some plays but what you had
when you didn't get top quarterback play
you had everybody loading up on Gurley
stopping him Darren the quarterback the
throat and it wasn't happening so you're
getting these 1413 games the defense
felt like they couldn't make a mistake
numb and and you didn't have to take
chances against in defense because if
somehow you scored 12 points 13 points
you're gonna win well now all the sudden
you load up the box and jarred golf
makes some plays and make some throws
now you say I can't do that I got to
play normal defense now Todd Gurley
looks like we expected Todd Gurley to
look now you're scoring points the
defense is ahead
10 off and the cumulative effect is
great but it was really just getting
that and Sean McVeigh has done a great
job with Jared Goff getting him to
perform well come back with Tony Dungy I
got a couple pointed questions what do
you do if you're the Colts with Andrew
Luck and I want to ask you what you do
if you're Ben McAdoo with Eli Manning is
a time to start looking at the future
well continued with Tony Dungy we also
talked about the Cowboys situation with
Ezekiel Elliott and how good this team
is and are they a Super Bowl contending
team we'll talk about that and your
phone calls coming up best and worse the
weekend as well half past the hour Dan
Patrick show Tony Dungy joining us on
behalf of Continental Tire coaches
corner from Sunday rain to snow and
everything in between Continental tires
engineered tire for what you do
extraordinary performance reliability
putting confidence into driving for more
information and a location of a dealer
near you visit Continental Tire Kham
Kham tire for what you do if you're been
McAdoo and perhaps in the final months
of your job with the Giants do you bench
Eli Manning I don't because I'm trying
to win as many games as I can to keep my
job if I'm been McAdoo I think this is
an organizational decision that they
have to make are we in a mini one-year
rebuilding program do we think we can
put the pieces back together next year
or is this start from scratch we've got
two or three years until we're going to
contend again and if you think that's
the case as a GM and as the owner then
now you can look down the road but I
think if I'm been McAdoo I'm trying to
win as many games as I can I think Eli
gives them the best chance to win right
now but you got to get their attention
something gets their attention if you
bench the starting quarterback or you
bench Eli out but you know what then
when I coach you know how I've got
people's attention gentlemen I want your
attention you had the right people
though that listen to you I don't think
these guys are listening to I think
they've tuned in mouth then you got to
get different people but you know if you
have to get people's attention by doing
that like the Adam GaSe thing and I'm a
Miami fan but if you have to trade
somebody to get people's attention you
don't have the right people there -
Andrew Luck's
future is it in Indianapolis I think it
is but I'm concerned about his physical
health and you know where is he because
we're he's gonna throw no he's not gonna
throw he's not throwing 100% we thought
he's gonna be ready he's not ready where
is he physically that the the reason why
I say it's gonna be an Indianapolis
think back five years and Peyton Manning
and supposedly he's done and he's got
this neck surgery and he'll never throw
again and he goes when wins a Super Bowl
for another team I don't see Jim Irsay
wanting to have that happen hey where's
Andrew Luck he's not playing and he wins
for somebody else I think you been in
Annapolis but how do they make this
mistake Tony where the owner says he's
gonna be ready week one and now they
shut him down for the rest of it
everybody thought it was gonna be ready
and and I don't know that that's what
baffles me they went in with really no
plan that Andrew wasn't gonna be there
and then they had to rush out and get
Jacoby percent right before the opening
on the regular season tells me they were
expecting him to play why it didn't
happen why Luck can't play at all this
year that's baffling if I look at the
first-place teams here and I say let's
go to the final week of the season who
is still in first place of these teams
Patriots
yes Steelers yes Titans mmm Jacksonville
has got a great defense all right
Chiefs yes Eagles yes
Vikings yes Saints that's no Carolina in
South Carolina could catch the same
Saints are playing well I love what
their defense is doing can they keep
going with that defense the rest of the
year I'm not sure Jags are the Titans
Ryan and I were talking about this on
the show last night
I love the Jags defense what they're
doing shutting people down coleus
Campbell has been great Titans though
have won three in a row and Marcus
Mariota is playing at about 70% capacity
I'm gonna go see him on Wednesday you
know and interview him for our following
Thursday night game we've got the Titans
in Pittsburgh I want to find out where
are you marked when are you gonna start
to be Marcus Mariota again is this gonna
be all usually healthy though he's not
help you he
sitting in the pocket not taking off
they're not running the read options
with him that really limits their
offense if they get that part back if he
tells me hey my hamstrings coming and
I'm gonna be marcus mariota in two more
weeks I think they can win it if he
asked that throat from the pocket and
just be a limited quarterback all year
then I like Jacksonville the Rams
Rams are legit and I'm I'm not liking
what I see in Seattle now Seattle's got
the experience and those guys can can
bounce back but I think the Rams are
more complete team right now but Tony
you're a defensive minded coach you play
defensive back explain to me two minutes
to go and the Redskins have to score a
touchdown and you're playing bump and
run I can't explain that then I was
watching it and I didn't believe it I
had just seen I tweeted out Dwight
Freeney with a spin move sack I had that
was 15 years ago I saw that and he's
rushing they're rushing the passer like
crazy Kirk Cousins doesn't have time to
get anything off they've got to go 70
yards you just sit there Haywood sit
back play zone make him make eight or
nine throws we're gonna get a couple sex
in here and the game's gonna be over
bump and run in the slot 30-yard Plate
bump and run on docks another 30 yard
player at the one-yard line in two plays
crazy I could not believe it the Cowboys
did felt like we're Ezekiel Elliott team
last year
are they dak Prescott team this year
they're definitely deck Prescotts team I
was down there week one to interview
deck he told me the difference last year
he got no reps with the first team until
Tony Romo got hurt in training camp so
all the offseason program training camp
he's kind of working with the second
unit he gets thrust in there we're gonna
build this around the running game and
play defense and he did a tremendous job
last year under the circumstances but
this year from day one offseason program
workouts many camps he's the guy he
feels confident they feel confident in
him yeah they need Ezekiel Elliott when
he's running the ball it makes
everything easier
but if Zeke goes on this suspension they
will still win games deck we'll just do
a little bit more and Shaun Lee yeah
such a difference with that team when
he's in there the defense is totally
different to me
yeah one really is with Shawn link Tony
Dungy joining us Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
you don't have to name names but did you
ever have somebody come in to interview
draft pick wise where you just went no
way we had a few of those what's a red
flag for you back when you were coaching
red flag to me you know who I used to
talk to Dan the equipment managers at
the school at the school yeah tell me
about this guy is he a pain in the butt
is he a guy that we want on our team and
those guys to tell you how you treat the
equipment managers the trainer's the the
academic advisors they could give you a
good clue but you know the coach is
gonna tell you oh he's a great guy yeah
you want him he'll do it anything for
you or we'll get scouts well it's good
for their program if you're taking yeah
and then we get Scouts well their
coaches couldn't get out he's really a
great guy and talented you can get it
out of him I never wanted those again
but we have these mock drafts and I
always tell people these aren't the
professionals who are gonna get their
hands on these kids and really dissect
them because how many times do we say
Matt Berkeley is gonna be the number one
quarterback Christian Hackenberg is
gonna be the number one quarterback and
then all of a sudden you go wait what
had then we view these kids as
disappointments it's not until you get
to the combine where you go okay now I
get a chance to talk to them do my
research did you ever have any but are
you gonna have guys scouting the college
ranks at what point are they do you have
your scouts looking at guys that you can
draft this next season oh they're
looking at them as as freshmen and
sophomore they're keeping track all the
way through and you get there and you
want to know everybody looks at Talent
this guy's talented this guy's great
this guy runs for three but what are
they gonna do what kind of teammates are
they gonna be how are they gonna fit
into what you do I wasn't there in Indy
but there was a debate Peyton Manning
and Ryan Leaf a big debate and there
were a lot of people who said Ryan had
more upside you know Peyton's been well
trained there's a lot of people who
revision his history they've changed
everybody knew Peyton was going to be
better it was close it was it was close
it was tight but when you talk to them
when you sat down that drive the Peyton
you know it was special and unique and
you once you interviewed the guys then
it was an easy decision Ricky Williams
and Edgerrin James Bill Polian got
killed for taking Edgerrin James / Ricky
Williams but when you told you miss out
on
who's the guy where you went I just
didn't know and I know I'm not being
fair to you because obviously there's
other people who missed out on players
but was there one that you just look
back and you go how did I miss that you
know it's hard off the top of my head
right now Randy Moss was one you know
where you said boy left Notre Dame under
cloud oh the marshal you hear all these
things should we take Randy Moss and and
Denny green you know
said hey this is a guy I believe in
Randy and if you if you believe in him
he's gonna do it for you Dante Culpepper
were you in Minnesota at the time okay
but but Denny Denny decided to go all in
go all in we had just the opposite way
and it turned out great for me
warren sapp the year Warnes coming out
and we're picking a number 11 I think at
Minnesota Denny says hey we've done all
our research we hear these rumors about
Warren but we're gonna if he's there
we're going to take him the morning of
the draft the next day we get this
communication from the league office
then he comes in we're not taking it I
never got an explanation why but we went
from we can take him to not take him
overnight
I'm defensive coordinator we already had
John Randall I don't think chris doumitt
we can have one of the best defenses of
all time
Denny says we can't take him I got to
move on he goes to Tampa to pick after
us and I was now I'm thinking gosh not
only playing against him twice a year
and the next year I'm the head coach in
Tampa so the Lord was looking out for
him who did you take Derrick Alexander
we took Derrick Alexander and there was
no question an inability no Peyton
Manning is doing what in five years I
tend to think he's in the front office
somewhere Cleveland Browns I don't know
that some somewhere exactly when Browns
tongue I've talked to patient about what
he wants to do and he's balancing TV and
going into what we do versus front
office he loves football he loves that
day-to-day interaction but I think in
his heart he knows if he goes to a team
it's gonna be twenty hours a day would
you follow him would I follow him yeah
yes I would I think I think he'll be
great at putting - he spent so much time
around Bill Polian he understands the
game nobody follow I mean would you work
with Peyton personally work with him
I'll be 70 years old 67 Dick LeBeau is
like 90 you know man said I want you to
be in my organization I would have to
think about that even if it's the
Cleveland Browns I can't get my wife
[Laughter]
could move to Clearwater Florida
okay Tony always great to see it we
appreciate it and I know you're joining
us on behalf of Andy Roddick's
foundation and you brought in some
listeners so yeah thanks for hosting
these guys we've had a great time at our
show last night and here today thank you
Continental Tire Coach's Corner east
Tony Dungy and he'll be working Thursday
night the Seahawks against the Arizona
Cardinals for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]